podría ser la última oportunidad para
determinar los orígenes del sars coft 2
o kobe 19 la organización mundial de la
salud nombró a los 26 miembros del nuevo
grupo científico asesor que tiene como
misión investigar sobre cómo surgió la
pandemia entre otras enfermedades el
equipo está compuesto por biólogos
epidemiólogos y especialistas de todo el
mundo no no hubo ningún proceso político
asociado a esta selección y ciertamente
necesitamos que naciones fuertes con
poder científico formen parte del
proceso pero son sus científicos los que
necesitamos no sus políticos -entre para
la crisis en febrero de este año una
misión de expertos de la oms se viajó a
la ciudad china de wuhan donde se
registraron los primeros casos del
patógeno según su informe conjunto el
virus probablemente se había transmitido
de los murciélagos a los humanos a
través de otro animal pero alegaron que
la investigación se vio obstaculizada
por la escasez de datos brutos relativos
a los primeros días del brote por ello
el comité insta a china a proporcionar
más datos y admitir nuevas misiones
internacionales al país
lo que necesitamos que haga este grupo
es evaluar urgente donde estamos en lo
que sabemos y lo que no sabemos y lo que
hay que hacer urgentemente tras la
última misión a china hubo más de tres
docenas de estudios recomendados que
debían llevarse a cabo esperamos obtener
una actualización de estos estudios para
poder decir bien esto es lo que sigue
por lo que este grupo asesor
proporcionará asesoramiento a la o ms
sobre los próximos pasos urgentes
el cómic 19 deja ya casi 5 millones de
fallecidos el organismo intenta
esclarecer los orígenes de la pandemia
que paralizó el mundo e intentar evitar
así futuras enfermedades